مخيم نور شمس الواقع في محافظه طول كرم
شمالي الضفه الغربيه يشهد مواجهات بين
قوات الاحتلال والشبان والمقاومين
الفلسطينيين الذين يتصدون لمحاولات قوات
الاحتلال اقتحام المخيم وتنفيذ اعتقالات
بحق الشبان هذا المخيم يشهد محاولات من
قبل قوات الاحتلال لاقتحامه منذ فجر يوم
الخميس التا عش من اكتوبر الا ان
المواجهات التي وقعت بين المقاومين وقوات
الاحتلال اوقعت 12 شهيدا حتى اللحظه واكثر
من 10 جرحى بالاضافه الى مقتل جندي
اسرائيلي اعترف به جيش الاحتلال هذا
الجندي كان من وحده المستعربين الشبان
قاموا بتفجير عبوات ناسفه بالقوات
المحاوله للاقتحام واطلقوا النار بشكل
كثيف وهم يواصلون القتال لمنع قوات
الاحتلال من الدخول الى المخيم والقاء
القبض على الشبان المقاتلين ب بداخله فيما
ايضا استخدمت قوات الاحتلال المسيرات
ل تنفيذ هجمات باتجاه الشبان كما قاموا
باخراج المصابين من سيارات الاسعاف ومنعوا
وصول سيارات الاسعاف الى المنطقه
لمساعده الشبان والمصابين بداخل هذا
المخيم هذا المخيم بات قلب المعركه بين
الشبان والمقاومين في منطقه شمالي الضفه
الغربيه وبين قوات الاحتلال تماما كما
تشهد الضفه الغربيه في اكثر من مدينه
مواجهات متواصله بين الشبان وقوات
الاحتلال منذ بدء معركه طوفان الاقصى